hey youtubers is Charlie so you may have
heard Marvel and Fox are teaming up for
two new TV shows based on x-men
properties the first one is gonna be a
60s Hellfire Club like set back in the
60s the others gonna be show about
Legion the the son of Professor X I know
there's a lot of questions about who
owns the rights to what because
technically Fox owns x-men rights Marvel
has almost everything else not including
spider-man you know pending Sony sharing
agreement but here's the deal Fox only
owns the rights to do x-men movies they
don't have the TV rights Marvel still
owns those so because Fox has a huge
x-men franchise they of course want to
capitalize that in their big TV business
so they had to come to terms just like
Marvel came to terms with Sony over
spider-man so Marvel and Fox will be Co
producing these two new TV series we
know a little bit more about what's
going on with the Legion TV show it's
gonna air on FX that's the same channel
that does American Horror Story the
strain Sons of Anarchy has a bunch of
good shows it'll be basic cable so they
can make it as crazy as they want to
there a lot more rules about the major
broadcast networks so like shows that
are on NBC Fox the other really big
channels they can't be quite as graphic
most of the fun of the Legion character
is that he has crazy superpowers he has
a bunch of different superpowers but he
has multiple personality disorder with
each personality controlling a different
superpower so if you know about the
Lucifer TV show that Fox is doing it's
it's kind of like that idea you have a
character that's not really a good
person but it's gonna be a lot of fun to
watch the way they talk about Marvel and
Fox working together it sounds like the
légion show is gonna be produced at
Marvel with a lot of input from the Fox
people for the most part the physical
production itself will happen with
Marvel resources now just sidestepping -
the Hellfire Club that's a bit more of a
known property because they're primarily
going to flow from the energy of x-men
first class although I don't think
they're gonna use a lot of those actors
they'll probably recast a lot of people
but they have access to all the big ones
so they'll be able to do Sebastian Shaw
Emma Frost I'm kind of hoping they don't
bring January Jones back she was like
the least interesting part of that movie
but it unlike the Legion show is gonna
be more of like a Fox production with
input from Marvel creatively Bryan
Singer's attached to executive produced
he's done a couple big TV shows in the
I think like the biggest one recently
was house m.d. but it only makes sense
that he is kind of like the shepherd of
the x-men franchise at Fox right now so
naturally he's gonna get involved in
their biggest TV series most of my
interaction with x-men on Fox TV has
been through the animated series like
the classic ninety series one of my
favorite cartoons of all time you watch
it now it's a little bit slow but the
stories mostly hold up they're really
good the way I think about the Hellfire
Club in the x-men universe is the way
most people think about the Inhumans in
the Marvel Universe technically they're
powerful but they've always kind of been
this weird little offshoot group like
most people when they think about x-men
team-ups they think about the x-men
themselves Professor Xavier's x-men and
then they think of the Brotherhood of
mutants or even like the Morlocks the
Hellfire Club was always unique because
it kind of invoked a lot of blood period
drama you have these very anachronistic
seeming characters they seem out of
place no matter when they're living even
in the sixties Sebastian Shoppe have
been living for a long time like you
know flashback to him being a Nazi so
just from a visual perspective expect it
to look similar to the look of the 60s
in the x-men movies if you want to read
about the Hellfire Club in the comics
something relatively recent that's
actually use them in an interesting way
is x-men legacies starting with a 2012
run most people say like older Hellfire
Club like the classic stuff kind of
sucks so you can like skip a lot of that
stuff just start with a 2012 legacy run
now the first time they actually showed
up was x-men 129 by Chris Claremont and
John Byrne they they were the ones that
created the Hellfire Club and the most
notable people that have been part of
the club are Sebastian Shaw of course
Emma Frost the White Queen
Harry Leland Donald Pierce Tessa Selene
who's kind of like the opposite of Emma
Frost who's kind of an even more evil
version of Emma Frost
then there's magneto who's been a part
of it briefly storm shinobi Shaw
Trevor Fitzroy Madeline Pryor who's
actually a pretty cool character satyr 9
Phoenix and sunspot so they've actually
had a pretty big membership I'm not
expecting them to have all those
characters some of the x-men people will
be movies only it's the same thing with
DC TV shows in the film's Fox just like
DC probably feels like it can earn more
money off of certain characters if
they're only in the films than if
they're also on TV shows like they feel
like sometimes having characters on TV
shows D values then maybe they just my
piñon I think they're trying to keep
certain people from getting overexposed
but they don't want Jean Grey becoming
the Phoenix on TV if she's gonna be
doing it on like a giant widescreen
movie projector but they actually
haven't made any official comments about
who they're gonna cast for the show
which characters they're gonna use just
expect to see the core Hellfire Club
people just expect them to have fun with
some of those tropes it's just like the
way Smallville used the idea of check
made in different chess pieces for
different people in the organization or
exposure to the Hellfire Club and the
movies was relatively limited and they
didn't get it really into the minutiae
of the actual club it was really just
sebastian shaw and acting his plans for
world domination you didn't see a lot of
like what was going on between people
inside the club Hellfire Club showed up
in uncanny x-men but legion showed up in
New Mutants which also heavily featured
x-force and Deadpool a lot a lot of
other things that we're gonna be seeing
from Fox there is still an x-force movie
floating out there somewhere they just
they won't make it till after they're
done with Deadpool so let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
the idea of x-men live-action TV shows
with Hellfire Club characters everybody
has like their favorite x-men characters
most of them tend to be film only an
attempt Oh has like a slightly better
shot of jumping to the TV shows
depending on how much money his movie
makes they might not be quite as
protective of him in the film universe
Fox x-men gonna be a lot of fun they're
not too afraid to do edgier TV shows so
think of it as being like slightly
edgier than what's going on in the CW
right now unlike the flash and arrow
they didn't announce a premiere date but
they can actually turn pilots over
pretty quickly when deals have been made
usually the problem is it's just like
making that arrangement with the other
studio if you need the rights to
something so what they might do is shoot
a pilot sometime next year for like a
2017 air date if the shows get picked up
now they haven't been picked up
officially like they haven't like
greenlit the entire run they just
started development on pilots but if it
turns into a thing I will totally do
videos for it every week if there are
any x-men videos that you guys want me
to do or Deadpool videos just let me
know in the comments I'm due for a new
Deadpool video soon that movie is
actually coming out in February just in
case you guys haven't seen in a while
you can click here for my last Deadpool
video and you can click here for my
arrow episode 2 video from last night
they just introduced Anarchy on the show
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you